I want to talk about gutsy your new
series on Apple
because you tackle
pretty much every subject with multiple
interesting people some you know the
most some you will discover which I love
that you had people who we recognize and
know so well
um Amy Schumer Kim Kardashian Megan the
stallion Glenn and Doyle I mean the list
is so incredible all the people but then
all the people we have never met and
will never forget and we need to know
because we need to know their stories
and we need their inspiration
I think it is going to be a model
of a format and a show moving forward
I've never seen anything like it it is
incredibly diverse in people and subject
but there's a cohesion and a format
there but I think you will see imitators
and imitations that has form a flattery
moving on because I've not seen a show
come together this way that really means
a lot to us Drew because we knew we
wanted to use the platform we have to
shine a light on women who were gutsy
and of course
we think that means that you're
courageous you're brave you're
determined uh you're resilient but we
wanted to highlight women who were using
that gutsiness to help other people yeah
because there are a lot of gutsy people
who do right things
and you know we were just talking about
the climate and one of the highlights of
the entire production was Chelsea got to
interview Jane Goodall and it was so
very incredible
um she's admired Jane Goodall since she
was like a little kid when I would you
know talk to her or tell her about this
amazing woman so it was just so uh fun
for me to get to hear Jane Goodall uh
speak like a chimpanzee which she does
in the interview and do that and drink
whiskey and like I think it was three
o'clock for her so it's so socially
acceptable when you're Jane Goodall 100
yeah so she's so cool too yeah I was
like I'm drinking coffee this is sad
isn't it but it's okay I mean I love
that you chose the word gutsy we talked
about the dictionary is expanded yet
again and added new words gutsy is like
Moxie there's an awesome yeah yeah so
good like from your gut you're doing the
right thing I think it describes a woman
too in such a cool sexy empowered way I
mean you chose she persisted for your
series you know the girls and I read
every single book you've ever written we
love them so much it's again another
show of gutsy women
um something really struck me when I was
watching the documentary amongst a
hundred things but you choose to start
out this series with comedians which got
me very excited because I love comedy
it's my medicine it's my coping
mechanism but then you talk about how
comedians made fun of you yeah yeah yes
well and how I had to go on a journey
with comedy because my first experience
with kind of formal comedy was being
made fun of as a kid and that felt
wacky and wrong to me like why are these
adults making fun of a child
you know seems like that shouldn't have
happened but it did and so I then
thought Drew like well that's just what
comedy is and it wasn't until
um candidly the making of gutty that I
met these amazing women comedians who is
you know Wanda Sykes said are you know
if they're throwing rocks they're
throwing them up they're throwing them
up at people who have power to make a
point about how that power could be
better used for people who don't have as
much power whether you're a child or a
woman or a person of color remember the
lgbtq community or any community that
historically has been left out of the
white male patriarchy and not throwing
rocks down and also the people who made
it clear they're using comedy to bring
people together they're maybe using
company to make fun of themselves to
invite us all to then be self-reflective
and laugh at ourselves and so it as I
say in this series was the intervention
I didn't know I needed
to really appreciate what comedy can be
like for us for our friends for our
families and for our communities that it
can be medicine
[Music]